ma è piena di trappole queste Escape
Room è bellissima
pieno di robot
[Musica]
poliziotti c'abbiamo dalla poliziotta
Ebbene sì questa volta siamo nuovamente
in prigione Ma questa volta invece di
scappare dal poliziotto dobbiamo
scappare dalla poliziotta eccola lì non
c'è scritto un nome quindi scrivete un
nome voi nei commenti Secondo voi come
si può chiamare questa poliziotta che
però quella divisa devo dire sì ma la
faccia non è molto simpatica È davvero
un po' storta
Dunque Mettetevi comodi Però tipo Carlo
lasciate un mi piace iniziamo assieme
questa nuova Escape Room facile
vediamo facile Ehi cosa ci fai con i
tuoi piedi sopra la mia testa prima di
tutto qua fermo
la torta aspetta
una torta Vedi che c'è la torta la
prendo ovviamente Vitale dove va nuotare
subito il cibo
non mangiamo assolutamente Wow
quindi ho capito la mamma ci ha dato una
torta per nascondere dietro una
chiocciola
Probabilmente questo cucchiaino ci
aiuterà ad evadere
tipo
sbaciucchiato perché sbaciucchiato qui
eh Lo vedi che è sbaciucchiato dice
raccogli Guarda guardati le guance Cioè
quindi questo era il poliziotto maschio
o la poliziotta la sbaciucchiato E l'ha
chiuso in prigione Boh non lo so perché
Ok prima lei ha detto i miei Preziosi
prigionieri come funziona perché è
Preziosi
non ci possiamo tirarle un colpo di
cucchiaio in testa vai via Vai Via Vai
via Eh io sono solo riuscita a salire
qui sul letto a castello
Ok puoi prenderne due Oh che figo
prendiamo le due che cosa servono boh lo
sappiamo Beh Dobbiamo scavare il tunnel
immagino No faccio un attimo le mie
cosette
Ma che schifo
è meglio che le faccio qui le scoreggine
non la sotto Vabbè comunque qua c'è un
poster con me e c'è scritto un milione
di dollari
Io vedo me quindi vuol dire che siamo un
prigioniero molto prezioso Quindi quando
scapperemo lei si arrabbierà tantissimo
e lui che cosa dice Raccogli perché Cosa
dobbiamo raccogliere Infatti non ho
capito Ah Ovviamente con i robot
cominciamo
è arrivata anche un'altra giocatrice nel
frattempo Ok scaviamo il nostro tunnel e
vediamo dove ci porterò non funziona
Guarda c'è un buco ma ma eh Aspetta
fammi capire ma che cosa sono queste
dove siamo finiti attento Perché cadono
Quando quando quando sali su No è
difficilissima ti sei sfociata
Allora attenta a non andare qui dove
Cioè non fermare troppo tempo non
fermarti troppo tempo qui dovevo finito
di trappole queste Escape Room è
bellissima Io adoro le Escape Room con
tante cose con tante cose tante trappole
oh oh
sai che mi ricorda che vi ricorda anche
ah ah Anzi
Guardate come è affacciata qua così è
scappata così è scappata fai un passo
avanti le mie scarpe
Beh che schifo è riapparsa Come funziona
Non capisco paurissima questa cosa
prendi il cucchiaio preparati
Cos'è questo è l'unica arma che abbiamo
che cosa incontra la famiglia c'è
scritto
ma sono tutti in famiglia della
poliziotta Guarda laggiù ci sta ci sta
guardando il cannocchiale vuole
eh eh non so cosa vuole farci rimetterci
in prigione e ho una domanda Hai premuto
questo pulsante Sì sì certo perché non
succede niente se lo premo prova
Come sempre quando gioco io si pagano i
giochi quindi devo fare a zero persone
al giorno
il cucchiaio
ciao ciao ciao per difendermi dalla
polizia Dai vai adesso almeno adesso
funziona qua Cioè guarda la famiglia
della poliziotta ho paura che quello
adesso
cadi nella Lava e la mamma forse o è lei
non lo so forse lei Questo è il padre
Questo è il fratello yeah è un robot
Questa è la sorella e questa è la mamma
eh
questo Vabbè capiamo Ecco un'altra
poliziotto che è stato messo qua dalla
poliziotta No no voglio comprare che
cavolo no Datemi le cose gratis per una
volta allora devi cliccare qui un paio
di volte per aprirlo e ora qui c'è un
evento
sono uscita fuori dal gioco per un
momento wow wow wow
bellissimo No io volevo continuare a
volare Se guardi sotto c'è lei no io
veramente qua sotto Vedo delle mie foto
eh vuol dire che ci sta cercando anch'io
Vedo delle mie foto Sta battendo con il
manganello
ma devo dire che sa che siamo scappati
certo col manganello a colpirci
Quindi cerchiamo di non farci vedere
come non detto
Non dobbiamo scappare aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
GoPro questa porta Nutella
olè aiuto entra qui nella cucina Ho
detto Lascia la pizza aiutami ti butta
pure giù io sono qua sopra ti vedo
dall'altra Ciao Anita Ciao Uhm
non credo che riuscirà a salire è
impossibile che salga qua è troppo
grande guarda Ok apriamo questo potere
Cioè premiamo questo bottone
figo Se cado giù mi prenderà la
poliziotta quindi andiamo piano non
cadere sotto dalla poliziotta Dai dai
risultati dietro l'angolo non fermi
niente vedi non abbiamo lo stesso colore
di vestiti ci piace il rosa tutti e due
aspetta un momento come faccio ad
arrivare laggiù devi saltare
Guarda guarda non è difficile si fa così
Hai visto ok lasciate Mi piace per
portarmi fortuna e forse riuscirò a
saltare qua Scommetto che cadrà ah ah
Med Scommetto che cadrà No dico la
poliziotta cadrà perché
che cosa è successo Cosa è successo
Allora innanzitutto c'è scritto
criminali andate via Qua c'è una porta
con una stanza per questi due Aiuto mi
stavo per prendere qua c'è la poliziotta
e questo era forse il padre con la madre
o la sorella non lo so non riesco a
capire che cos'è
Però vedi stanno usando le videocamere e
ti volevo dire che questi sono i laser
mi stanno colpendo non sono laser sono
una videocamere
tutte le porte sono bloccate tutte tutte
forse tranne queste due ore sono aperta
ho aperto questo
capito C'è tipo una poliziotta zombie
che mi ha preso Eh sì però sono viva
adesso Dai vieni qua questa la porta sei
sicura che si apre E certo l'ho aperta
non lo vedi che è aperta no Io la vedevo
chiusa veramente Ah ho capito dobbiamo
prendere la scatola mettendo qualcuno
vabbè vabbè ho capito Ciao si fa così ok
Non so come faremo a liberarti dalla
poliziotta cattiva ma forse rimarrai lì
per sempre addio
Allora proviamo a mettere la sedia Ah
quindi dobbiamo salire fino a sopra con
tutte le sedie Ok proviamo
allora un po' difficile qua Ok perfetto
Ma perché
Ma che cavolo è troppo difficile Anita
Togliti Togliti tu no Togliti
però
bagni
C'è scritto no cioè vuol dire che siamo
schiappe
facendo la cacca
che puzza
abbiamo beccato la poliziotta in bagno
strano che non si è arrabbiata e non c'è
sfracellato non aprire la terza porta
Non aprire quella porta che cosa ci sarà
nella terza porta ti ho detto non aprire
troppo curiosa vediamo
Hahaha
Ma chi ha lasciato no aspetta Ma questa
questo non è una cosa normale qua può
essere passato solo un elefante Cioè non
è normale questa non mi aspettavo che
era poliziotta facesse questi mostri Ma
vabbè andiamocene via subito da qua Che
schifo via
meglio stare nelle fogne che stare lì
Guarda infatti siamo nelle fogne Questo
almeno sono più colorate sono verdi
evitare che stava per cadere ma non è
caduto tutta la domenica ho spaccato
poco poco no attento questi cosi cadono
velocissimo e poi questi qua sono ancora
più difficili perché scendono
lasciateli chiusi
c'è la poliziotta la tua che cosa c'è in
testa c'è qualcosa in testa un martello
credo che siano due bombe per noi
si è aperto Tutto qui
no mi hai spinto hai capito
Ciao Non è vero il gabinetto della
poliziotto Ah ah ah sto continuando a
cadere Che cosa hai fatto la maledizione
della cacca della poliziotta no
E beh ci credo
non dobbiamo svegliarla Ok Fammi passare
non riesco a passare qui
ho un dubbio che dubbio Qua c'è un
prigioniero che potrei anche liberare
sempremo Lì però non ha una faccia molto
simpatica Magari se lo liberiamo magari
ci aiuta ho svegliato ci fa qualcosa Non
lo so che facciamo rischiamo dai
proviamo a liberarlo Vediamo che succede
Ma sì dai vedi
non ci credo
No OK riproviamo Questa volta non libero
proprio un bel nessuno
svegliare la poliziotta penso per te
rimarrai lì per sempre ragione
Ecco gli altri Allora
[Musica]
praticamente qui c'è una porta con un
lucchetto e dice apri e come facciamo ad
aprirlo se ci manca la chiave ho capito
Sai cosa dobbiamo fare dobbiamo liberare
quei prigionieri e trovare la chiave e
poi fare velocissimo perché sveglieranno
la poliziotta prendiamo questo
proviamo ad aprire questo Vediamo come
si apre
forse dobbiamo aprirli tutti in ordine
ce la faremo mai a prendere la chiave
così
capiamo velocissimo Ok via via via via
veloce veloce
e con la sta arrivando sta arrivando
sarà nel terzo la chiave Sì ma allora la
stanno combattendo invece quindi tre
forze ci riescono non riusciamo ma Aiuto
Aiuto Sono sconfitta
abbiamo trovato la chiave adesso tu di
lei la chiave quindi in realtà erano
nostre alleati non nostri nemici
scappiamo apriamo No non si apre non
prendere
XVIII secolo
Wow belli dove sei tu e io sono seduta
davanti sto guidando la locomotiva che
bello dove stiamo andando Non lo so da
questa parte mi viene in vita Ah ma sei
dietro di me ok
o no o no
No no dall'altra parte perché ho le
braccia così Boh Ecco no devo correre
sulla Cellato
è difficile perché non va proprio molto
veloce
la velocità del vento l'aria che ci sta
trasportando ma non è la super velocità
preferisco la super velocità Dai ti
manca poco sono qui ti vedo la Rita ciao
[Musica]
ti stai mangiando tutti i dolci no no no
no no perché l'hai avvisata pronta avete
bisogno di trovare la chiave adesso come
facciamo a trovare la chiave OK
riproviamo Forse ho capito bisogna
prendere questo fucile a pompa qui
gigantesco
e dobbiamo colpirla
Guarda diventa sempre più grassa hai
visto uh uh Guarda che cibo diventa
gigante
questo Escape Room È troppo bella finora
mi sta piacendo tantissimo Wow c'è la
macchinina per fare la corsa
troppo bella questo schifo proprio Dio
Ma come si fa a vedere avevo detto Gigi
ha scritto Le ruote si piegano per tutti
tipo planare ah ah troppa È troppo bella
questa parte bellissima Wow Pure nel
tubo è stupendo Voglio anch'io una
macchina così che salta come con le
ruote
ogni tanto bisogna saltare credo che
stai andando indietro Anita eh Da
quest'altra parte Ma che dici Io sono il
tubo rosso Forse sei tu che stai andando
indietro che stai andando indietro
forse ti sei buggato Io sto andando
benissimo
nel tubo rosso Che figo è troppo
divertente questo Room
Uh questa parte con la macchinina della
mia preferita è troppo bella
moto Wow ci sono anche dei tappetini
elastici per saltare
Eh hai già preso No il badge no ah cosa
c'entra il Belgio coi tappetini elastici
Non lo so pensavo che avesse finito No
ci sono i tappetini è vivo Questa
macchina nel tempo
tappetino elastici mi vedo Vitale
[Musica]
è saltato fuori Mi sono appena tornato
con il tappetino è saltato fuori devi
saltare in avanti no fuori Vabbè io mi
butto da questo tunnel Ciao Che succede
che succede
Oh no C'è un altro nemico
c'è un robot che sta controllando
qualcosa sempre con la divisa da
poliziotta e poi qua credo che ci siano
dei prigionieri che sono stati
rinchiusi in una sorta di liquido verde
quindi forse stanno facendo degli
esperimenti sui prigionieri Aiuto Ho
paura di queste siano per noi c'è
scritto posiziono la testa ehm che è
successo Mi ha disintegrato con gli
occhi laser Ah dobbiamo sconfiggere la
poliziotta robot e poi posiziono la sua
testa qua dopo qualcosa il cucchiaio Sì
abbiamo bisogno di un'arma qualcosa non
c'è niente qua Ok Allora dobbiamo
guardare attentamente cerchiamo da
qualche parte forse questa cosa qua
sopra aiuta gli occhi laser aiuto
brava sì ho capito da quella parte Brava
stai andando bene proviamo ad andare là
Attento a non farti prendere dagli occhi
laser
sono caduta No no Ora riprovo
il laser e super arrabbiata è rimasta
abbandonata là dietro ho trovato anch'io
di vernice addosso Ok ora ci provo ma se
glielo tiro da qua sopra
ha funzionato Poi prendi la testa vedi
Io c'ho la testa alla sua testa in mano
Ok disegnata
libertà Libertà dobbiamo prendere un
drink qua e ora che guarda là sotto
Guardatela sotto che cosa c'è un
esercito pieno di robot
poliziotti Guardate proviamo ad
ingrandire Io pensavo che sono uscita
tantissimi se svegliamo con l'esercito
Non riusciremo mai a scappare da queste
cinque trucchi sono tantissimi quindi
come non detto ufficiale è caduta laggiù
evita le loro svegliano all'esercito No
no no Sono caduto dal vuoto nella parte
dell'esercito Oh mamma se quelle si
svegliano è la fine per noi non
riusciremo mai a scappare quindi non
cadere giù Ok No no sono super attento
Guarda qua c'è un trampolino via
piccolo sono tantissimi Sono arrivata
già Sono arrivata già gioca veramente
solo io in testa
non è vero ci sono io aspetta c'è
scritto esperimenti non andare cappa
Aiuto Sono una trappola ne dobbiamo
andare quella sarà l'uscita Vieni vieni
vieni Vediamo lo scopriremo presto
Avevi ragione C'è un esperimento andato
un po' male qui c'è la poliziotta in
versione gigantesca che vuole
spiaccicarci aiuto ma qui c'è un cannone
vedi e dobbiamo tirarglielo dobbiamo
mettere le palle del cannone forse qua
dentro dove saranno per forza da questa
parte Vieni vieni si è aperta una porta
qui
da dove siamo arrivati no ne ho preso mi
ha fatto stavo provando a passare da
quella parte Dai allora devi venire qui
c'è scritto eh premi Ok vediamo
Wow dove siamo dobbiamo mettere ho
capito dobbiamo salire qua sopra allora
mi fermo qui e poi qui e poi
posizioniamo la sedia qua sopra via
abbiamo evitato la poliziotta gigante Eh
ma che stai facendo Anita dove devo
andare Ah ecco bisognava stare Ecco la
palla di cannone tutti
abbiamo trovato Voglio sapere alla fine
del turno
Ah perché tu sei riuscito a passare già
però qua non mi fa passare Uffa quindi
dobbiamo tornare indietro non ho capito
niente Cosa non hai capito Devi salire
qua sopra stavo salendo dall'altra parte
Infatti Ok Ci sono anch'io Ecco anche
Vitale siamo pronti a fare esplodere la
poliziotta
non l'avrai arrabbiare vero
l'hai spedita Ah peccato speravo che
esplodesse proprio e poi non avremo più
riviste invece l'abbiamo solo
allontanata però Ma quanto è brutta è
bruttissima bello questo mi è piaciuto
Dai andiamo avanti andiamo Stanno
uscendo delle tracce di sangue eh C'è
qualcuno là forse non è il caso di
aprire vediamo bene uh
Ma come Ma ci siamo sfracellati Eccomi
robot
dice tutto in altre lingue
comunque date dovremmo andare adesso
credo qua quella parte dice di tornare
indietro torna indietro normale è troppo
tardi non mi fido di questo polpo non
possiamo più tornare indietro Dai
dobbiamo prendere anche quell'altro
pulsante così si aprirà la porta prendi
una chiave da una porta doppia sicurezza
Ecco aperta ora
allora levati di petto
devo dare prima io ce la farò ce la farò
ce la farò No è passato Anita uh ce
l'abbiamo fatta Allora c'è scritto che i
maschi vanno da un lato e le femmine
dall'altra
trova il bottone
c'era una grata sono arrivato con il
nostro gelato Ma come Sì devo tornare
troppo lo devo dare della parte rosa e
pure qua c'è il tubo Che strano comunque
siamo finiti in una sorta di asilo in
cui ci sono credo che questi siano i
figli della polizia urbana perché si
assomigliano stanno facendo il training
per diventare poliziotti Sì sì stanno
allenando per eliminare gli altri
giocatori
Dobbiamo trovare il bottone dove sarà
meno male non ci hanno visto o almeno
fanno finta di niente forse comunque
troviamo questo bottone prendiamo
vediamo dove sarà qua non c'è questa
porta non si apre
[Musica]
Ecco non hai trovato Bravo bravo ho
premuto il bottone ce ne sono altri io
ho solo questo
si è aperta la porta che figo
Buonanotte questo Eh senti andiamo pure
alla volta eh perché ho paura che ci
spingiamo Comunque io non ho capito una
cosa perché è diventato in prima persona
adesso
a spostare la visuale Ah sì Adesso sì
Ok ci sono riuscita attento a queste
parti cadono le parti arrugginite cadono
non cadere No
C'è mancato poco penso che ci siamo
quasi adesso Questa è la palestra
[Musica]
Come sarebbe la palestra non c'è niente
è tutto vuoto
hanno preso tutto
ora muscolosa che mi sta inseguendo
Allora non vengo
qui aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto Ecco
la polizzetto muscolosa scappiamo aiuto
Ok l'ascensore via via via Senti io non
so dove sono finito Ma boh non può
pericoloso e anch'io non so dov'è
esattamente
dai mi scappa da questa parte vieni
Vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni
Forse qui abbiamo il Cucchiaio d'oro Che
strano ci ha lasciato in pace strano
Qua c'è scritto qualcosa in polacco non
so cosa c'è scritto Forse ce l'ho fatta
credo che ci sia scritto di non andare
No no c'è scritto che devi scavare
praticamente dobbiamo scavare il muro
qui vedi scaviamo il passaggio scappiamo
presto Siamo quasi forse forse non
riuscirà Oh no guarda guarda guarda
guarda
questa immagine tre persone che cercano
di sconfiggere la poliziotta Quindi sarà
molto molto grande e poi noi siamo solo
in due dobbiamo
io non ce l'ho più cucchiaio ah ah credo
che questo ponte non ci Rega è una
trappola è una trappola non dobbiamo
andare di là devi andare
velocissimissimo ti puoi fermare solo
nelle mattonelle del colore diverso
capito
Vediamo se ce la fa abitare vediamo
Allora non ho capito come fare Anita Ah
sono hanno un timer tipo hai capito
ancora presto sbrigati sbrigati è salito
c'è la poliziotta gigante lì la vedi è
pronta
a
mangiarci
non credo che ci mangi però è
importantissimo
Sono scivolato Comunque è scomparsa bene
meglio così almeno non ci rincorrerà
forza per ora finora forse sono i teschi
di quelli che sono stati mangiati dalla
poliziotta Come hai fatto a passare da
quella parte prego
facciamo tipo
Non vedo l'ora guarda guarda dietro
eh eh Ma che succede stiamo volando
siamo fuori dal gioco C'è qualcosa di
strano ma che
cazzo c'è da gioco
E vabbè l'importante siamo riusciti Però
ad attraversare tutto Infatti
l'importante è che siamo riusciti a
uscire Ci sono dei cani dietro si è
murato tutto e adesso ci sono questi
cani Qui cani non li vedi no vabbè anche
i cani sono puliti con la divisa da
poliziotto Allora come possiamo fare
cagnolini
Bravo
finisce male
attenta perché aiuto
ci sono cani più grandi cari più piccoli
sono troppo divertenti Che carini troppo
carini Peccato che ci vogliono mangiare
però sono carini Guardate che cosa c'è
qua
non ci posso credere
bello
dobbiamo correre però corri corri corri
Wow devi saltare a un certo punto
Sì ti sei preso la Vecchia Torre
Ehi ma come si fa andare più veloce Ah
con la G Vai più veloce Non avevo capito
movimento G aumento G no niente niente È
troppo bella questo schifo pronti
una brutta notizia per te dopo che voli
c'è scritto è una trappola
Sì sì è proprio una trappola perché qua
c'è la poliziotta
ho un robot Sì che bello
sconfiggere la
poliziotto è proprio non capisco Ah ah
ah appena arriverà il qua nella trappola
capirai dobbiamo sconfiggerci dentro la
macchinina però non so perché è la parte
di sopra del robot non esiste Cioè
è invisibile Che figo cioè
mettiamola così sconfiggerlo per sempre
questa posizione spada ci dobbiamo
perdere Hahaha è troppo bello Beccati
questo beccati anche questo e questo No
io sono morta davvero ma bisogna Quindi
solo colpirla così e si no aspetta Io
non ho più il robot Eccolo
mi ha preso perché m'ha preso beccare
questa Beccati questo mi ha preso Eh sì
è un po' difficile bisogna ricominciare
poi tutto da capo bisogna solo
ricominciare questa sfida un po' dai
possiamo farcela dai dai dai dai dai
peccati questo però riesci a colpirla lo
stesso
motivo riesce a colpirla lo stesso anche
tu scappi vedi ho capito ho capito Ho
capito però è divertente manca
pochissimo c'è lei che ci sta
rincorrendo così scappiamo la colpiamo
all'indietro ce l'ho fatta l'ho
sconfitta
presto Scappiamo
Uh
l'elicottero non ci sta intorno
Che figo Guardate tutta la prigione
stupendo bellissimo
sta portando con te un'altra prigione
sembra un'altra prigione quella lì Qua
sei in mezzo andiamo vediamo siamo
saltati fuori dall'elicottero viva
abbiamo preso il peso fino anche detto
che ci abbiamo messo un sacco di tempo
Aspetta devo prendere il Trofeo ho preso
il Trofeo Evviva
19:47.19
19:42.99 Ah ah ah
Wow Super Salto Escape Room completa
mi è piaciuta tantissimo quindi che voto
gli date scrivetelo nei commenti ora vi
lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite eh
Buona visione Ciao